he's Baroque and he's got no prospects
I can't live like this wow he's broke
he's got no Prospect he has to be at the
top before you secure a thing you have
to have made it yeah I might start oh
God
[Music]
okay okay
demon just got out of the cat hey I get
my bro in advance hey I gave my bro
whatever anyway guys we're back
Fab I need to understand how they do
like you know in the oh yeah yeah I know
exactly
don't think
or the pumpkin
that vote drop
yeah I'm gonna pattern that for the live
show what's good guys as you already
know we go straight into the
nitty-gritty with a question of the week
and this question of the week was very
subtle this week but I thought it was a
good one what feels like a crime but
isn't
a lot of people were giving me
um a lot of people giving me driving
barefoot
I've never even I didn't know people did
that I've done it twice Barefoot not fun
I've done it probably once in socks
maybe no okay I don't think I've ever
done it Barefoot
I've done it in socks
[Music]
[Applause]
just because I was [__] doing
something in it I was like um busy in it
I was too busy for shoes I was probably
leaving someone's yard or something like
that I was too busy for shoes
um but it might I honest to God I don't
know why yeah I just did it and it was
scary oh you feel everything wrote
everything on that pedal wow
it's actually terrified pressing the
brake you don't feel strong enough yeah
yeah
a little bit forward it's vile yeah so
the barefooting was wild to me but
anyway what feels like a crime but isn't
facts watching a movie with your parents
and a sex scene comes on oh that's the
worst that is the worst I remember being
a kid and that happening it was
grotesque it's just like what do you
actually because it's not my fault that
there's there's sex on TV and it's not a
parent what do you do you just sit there
and watch it I used to hold my breath
I would sit there and just film my air
with my lungs with air and just sit
there and hope to pass out
it was the worst experience of my life
it's so awkward yeah yeah being a female
and having to fart
random first of all yuck yes I don't
know how to deal with it yeah yeah
you're not fighting in me yeah
because we keep it sexy and it's not
it's natural this is the okay cool I've
got two things to talk about real quick
first of all I have a I think I've gone
on a run about this one's probably
talking about periods in the day right
um
I hate when people use the guys of
natural to make things seem like they're
okay there are a lot of things in nature
that just aren't okay okay and farting
is one of them yeah and I'm sorry beer
is another yeah
I'm sorry because if girls didn't have
to do it then they wouldn't like no one
would choose to have one you know what I
mean okay yeah so that means it's not
okay
if 99.9 of people would say if I could
get rid of this I would yeah then that
means it's not okay so what aren't you
okay with the fact that they have their
periods no I'm not okay with the fact
that I'm not allowed to say that they're
not okay
they're yucky because they are yeah okay
because they're natural doesn't mean
they're not yucky just like Fast just
it's not yucky I'm with you okay I'm
with you it's like I hate this weird
area yeah the area that we're living in
it's not making sense I'm with you yeah
I'm fine anyway second thing okay oh
roll on my way here today
I thought I was in The Truman Show Vlog
one Brethren I went into Tesco Express
and there were two crackers chatting it
up outside for one yeah both of them
were high on crack yeah and they didn't
even know each other they were just two
random crackers chopping it up yeah
um and then I went in there I didn't
know each other you can tell you just
tell this is the first greet yes yeah
okay so yeah they're just chopping it up
and then I went to get my monster paid
for it on my way out the security guard
is standing there Stern looking at you
or just standing doing it straight okay
like an NPC like okay
he's looking straight on I'm like here
he's looking straight on
doesn't make eye contact with me sees me
coming here doesn't make eye contact
with me as I made it to here
this is assault by the way as I as I
made it to here ripped a thought
when I say the most gnarly fought I've
ever heard leave a human being
ripped out of him and when I say his
expression didn't change an inch no I
stopped fam honestly I was walking
walking and it was like
and I was like
bro I did yeah man just
Stern bro didn't move and I was like
where are the cameras yeah where are we
where literally where are we wow it was
weird bro but I went into beefing but I
was like I'm not staying around for the
smell yeah it smells good yeah yeah from
The Sound alone in this film yeah yeah
it's like did you you know what Step
Brothers where he rips out he's like I
thought it's gonna be silent there's no
way he thought that was gonna be fine
yeah yeah there's no way in the meeting
on interview or something yeah in the
interviews uh beside it it's like bro
there's no way that I was gonna beside
it and this guy didn't even think that
one was going to be silent he just knew
he had to push it out yeah like the talk
that came off of it he pushed it the
talk he pushed it it must have vibrated
bro in a shop there's food in here yeah
they have an open Bakery in there bro
they got pastries in there bro yeah man
just mustering up the air man there's
crop dusting around this test he didn't
even care I'm not paid to be polite I'm
paid to stop crying I'm on my guts to
hurt him I'm not stopping anything I
need to fart he was probably focused on
not trying to [__] himself yeah that's
the reason why I didn't move a muscle
it goes straight back up like in
Futurama
yeah bro it's tough bro it's vile back
to it what feels like a crime but isn't
watching an extra episode of a show
without your other half
that is a crime in some houses but I
also
yeah like we need to find out
like there needs to be rules because
like sometimes you're not in the mood to
watch it and I am true I want to binge
you and sometimes you're like oh this is
I don't know let's just watch come down
and I'm like oh no and we need to finish
this to finish this is Juicy yeah so
sometimes sometimes you need and then
I'm still not allowed to watch it it's
outrageous The Only Way is Essex
that is a crime
The Only Way is Essex you know
masturbating multiple times a day
it does it does feel like a crime bro it
really does it really does this there's
times do you ever get that secondhand
shame where like you've you've you've
fapped like three four times in one day
and you're
you're down bad yeah obviously yeah yeah
yeah like the whole day is true yeah
yeah
um you're damn bad bro and then you're
just like in a car or you could walk
around and your tools aching yeah and
you're like what what am I doing like of
course damage yeah to myself this is
self-inflicted pain
that's one of them ones where where you
feel like the urge to go again and it's
like why am I like this yeah bro why am
I like this there was a time a few
months ago I must have gone like three
racks yeah and like
I draws for the this is before my little
like Pawn cancellation okay I draws for
the phone for round four yeah and
touched my tools and it was sore and
sensitive I was like what am I doing
dude
yeah yeah seven seconds of joy
I'm putting up with pain
yeah the um the posts um the post shame
is the post not shame is
is so Peak especially when
we're different because you'd not let
her fly in it yeah let it go anywhere
I'm straight on my stomach bro I wipe
that [__] up I'm in the moment man you
man trying to catch stuff that's that's
what's really sick
[Music]
no
that's sick in the head bro I'm locked
in
and also I've got my phone in one hand
yeah and my dick in the other oh no
tactics yeah what I do is let's say I'm
in bed right let's say I'm in bed yeah
um I place the phone okay I'm tall
one-handed phone to the other right yeah
as it's going on
um let's say um 10 seconds away from
doing the deed yeah I plant my phone so
it's obviously I'm yeah also fun fact if
you ever see my phone
[Applause]
um
[Laughter]
cool so 10 seconds before I climax right
I actually I place my phone somewhere
where I can where it's still like facing
up yeah so like in between like the
duvet my skin it's where it's at so it's
just I can still see but my neck is Arch
like this so I'm like
he knows
nah bro I I get lost in it yeah phone
here yeah sometimes before you're here
sometimes I'm nose to nose of it and I'm
just hard because also I can't see my
talk okay I have like a disconnect I
can't see what I'm doing to myself it
throws me right out okay I need straight
Focus okay so the phone has to be here
the phone's literally here and I'm gone
and then bro it stays here yeah because
I need I still need three Strokes after
okay do you know what I mean okay like I
need to fully go yeah yeah yeah so I'm
going go go go
yeah
yeah yeah and then I Dash the photo I'm
like Jesus
and then that's when you're like yeah
you're scrambling for something yeah
grab a towel and then like
okay yeah that's when I roll out of bed
as well but yeah this this 10 seconds
out pause I don't pause
yeah yeah yeah yeah I try sometimes I
[__] up sometimes I [__] up bro so I
pray that obviously between my skin and
the thing and the duvet and because the
the degrees the axis is too much the
phone folds the phone falls all I'm
hearing is sound but I'm too far gone to
flip the phone back do you know what I
mean so it's chaos I'm not dealing with
that it's okay just to catching up yeah
let it fly bro let it fly enjoy yourself
[Laughter]
enjoy your life man what's through this
funny I never thought I'd say that on
the podcast funny
bro
[Laughter]
funny oh
my God oh my days being a man is torment
man it is it's so buzzed oh bro it
really really is back to it what feels
like a crime but isn't
when you funny enough when you boss a um
when you bus a bit too quick and can't
get it up for round two
facts bro facts we've all been there
that is uh yeah that's coaching stations
in the bathroom light on locked in
running yeah looking at yourself in the
mirror yeah Focus get it going bro lock
in man it's it's tough It's time you're
stroking as well trying to get started
and that makes it worse it does because
your tools are what are you doing yeah
literally I'm part of you like I know
you you can't trick me facts is so Jared
um what feels like a rainbow isn't
making eye contact with a police officer
bro I don't think I've ever made eye
contact with a police officer just wow
that's actually systemic I've never even
fought by a systemic fear I I never made
eye contact with a police officer that
hasn't hassled me just walk and do it
yeah yeah yeah I see one in McDonald's
yeah systemic wow yeah but Valentine's
Day facts wearing double denim facts oh
Jesus I I yeah I yeah I remember when I
wore down double denim one time I
remember exactly what I was wearing I
love that dead is the Menace I was I had
double I had um do you remember what was
those low like we used to wear those low
crotch jeans do you remember
[Music]
[Applause]
I was feeling myself I remember I had
burgundy Vans a pair of those jeans on I
know white and burgundy striped rolled
up t-shirt and then a denim
vest jacket on how far is the man bro I
went to lit my girl that day she was
like you look like a joke she said as
soon as she opened the door she said raw
double denim
that's what she said and I just spent
all my bursary on this
I just I just spent my entire grunt on
this outfit
feeling sexy openness
and I wanted to jump straight back on
the national Express
[Laughter]
jump straight back on it raw double
denim Peak
uh sleeping without texting your partner
good night
going through airport security
um
ass to mouth
[Laughter]
Raw
Raw that feels like a crime ass to mouth
dead to be fair it's not like actually
as a concept it's not but he's deep
when you dance or something says I'm mad
like I asked it just sounds sexy mouth
on a was it Human Centipede thing never
hmm
hilarious not taking the trolley back to
the store have you ever done that before
not taking it back to the store
you took it back but I took it home I
promise you when me and Bella first
moved into the um to the old spot
we went shop obviously at the yard was
empty went shopping shopping yeah um and
back then I didn't have the car
obviously you know the distance between
my spot it's a lot it's it's quick but
it's long yeah same time especially
carrying shopping yeah the trolley was
full we were like [__] let's just
take it to the yard took it all the way
to the other left upstairs everything
and I think she took it back yeah
in it
facts to be Fairfax accidentally liking
a pic from a year ago
I unlike it immediately facts saying no
to your mother
oh when's the last time I said no to my
mum has asked me for anything for me to
say no to be honest
I can't remember the last one so no
tomorrow I don't remember the last time
I'm gonna start
with a star yes I don't remember
needing a [__] after you've just had a
shower
wow I don't think that's ever happened
to me that's happened to me really yeah
I just jump straight back in afterwards
really yeah it's jarring now I've I
always because even if there's a I force
it out before the shower because we like
to marinate in the steam so yeah Buy in
Lube I scan paid and ran
that's more embarrassing than anything
must be that I've never bought Lube in
my life but I remember I've bought one I
was probably like I bought loophons
really yeah yeah how'd you feel to be
fair I felt fine because I was with my
girl at the time right
[Applause]
oh boy do you remember when I'm
um where is Amsterdam and uh who was it
who should have dildo my body do you
remember someone dug my back with a
dildo in the section
first time we went Amsterdam for your
birthday I don't remember this brother
well we was I think it was Jay
I fell to my neck
I don't remember hug me in my bag was a
massive dildo because I think you bent
over
you've been over to look for side and
your bike was shoved Bros on my hands
and knees
laughing I couldn't believe what I
witnessed
[Music]
yeah yeah it was and I was like this guy
bro
I didn't want to get up I bet I didn't
want to get up just finish me off bro at
this point honestly oh that's sweet in
me wow I forgot that happened I forgot
to happen bro uh last few what feels
like a crime but isn't
going the exact same way as someone
after saying goodbye
that happened to us with Jay the other
day at the hotel do you remember oh yeah
I hated that yeah I almost wanted to
walk a mile round to come back yeah I
hated that and then he he doesn't play
with like he doesn't play along with
that stuff so he turned around was like
what are you doing just walk bro we both
know what happens relax
ing him to put a condom on
yeah that's it kills the vibe no matter
what it does it does skipping as a means
of transportation
and the last one trying to parallel park
when there's traffic behind you
fear that you can't you can't [__] up
yeah you can't you have to get it in one
perfect yeah you can't get him too you
can't you can't oh my you're hearing
beeps you're better off like doing it
grandma style bare slow as opposed to
like trying to want it and then [__]
up and then they'll move forward and
then you have to come out again
oh it's the worst but yeah um that was
the question of the week guys yeah man
welcome to the show welcome back welcome
back welcome back
I just followed too quick because I want
to do the intro I'm sorry bro welcome
back guys obviously you already know the
drill you know what it is man if you
want to be uh an official cult baby if
you want to enjoy bonus episodes if you
want to be a member of our Discord if
you want to jump on a zoom call with
your boys once a month you need to head
on over to patreon.com forward slash
shits and gigs and it's gonna cost you a
very very minor three pound a month 10p
a day these run the pizza sng so we can
continue to live lavish
um it's important to us there's a cost
of living crisis and like the viewers
need to
experience
joy and vitality vicariously through us
so we're gonna need cake for that facts
and you guys are gonna have to provide
it so anyway guys head over to patreon
today binge three years worth of our
content see all the old stuff when we
were coming up see the uncensored stuff
that never got chopped out see the stuff
that should have got us canceled but
didn't over on patreon and if you are
watching on YouTube please please please
subscribe to the channel it means the
world to us we're on a mission to hit a
million Subs not many podcasts do that
you know not many podcasts managed to do
that so we're trying to we're trying to
change it up
um as you guys have noticed we're
pushing the the production here we're
trying to up the editing
um and uh the the feedback so far has
been amazing so thank you guys lastly
guys if you are listening on any audio
platform please leave us a nice review
please follow the show please give us a
five star rating if you're feeling
generous uh but whatever you do say it
would be chest
and that's it man I think we are going
to play a little game because REM is
back in the studio for a couple weeks
away let's go let's go and we have a top
five quiz today top five top five top
five so yeah as per everyone grab your
boards grab your pens guys at home make
sure you're playing make sure you're
writing in the comments
um this top five is actually different
so it's not an actual top five I'm
asking you five questions if you're
asking us five questions yeah but it's
it's it's all um topic based so it's
called top five Capital Cities
so after each question I'm gonna ask you
to reveal your answer and I'm gonna
grade it all right cool what is the
capital
of Australia is that your question
no
it's not a trick question but
it's not what you think it is it's not
Sydney is it no
[Laughter]
uh what is the capital of Australia all
right Ram go first what have you got
what have you got couldn't think of
other place but Sydney yeah I couldn't
think of it Sydney Melbourne Melbourne
you're all wrong
Canberra what yeah
yeah yeah
who's heard of that
everyone else apart from you three
apparently swear did you know that no of
course not then
so everyone else apart from YouTube
ah rude capital city of Brazil everyone
written another yeah yeah I have nothing
all right say less there's a weird city
in Brazil it's called like Brazil or
Brasilia or something like that okay so
what did you write I wrote Brasilia okay
but it says Brazil so if I rub out the
last little bit
I can get it right that's right
what did you write
Sao Paulo most people would write that
yeah it's actually Brazilian yeah
sick guys
next one
the largest capital city in Europe oh
the largest capital city in Europe daddy
that's a tricky one yeah that is okay
Ellis what you got Tommy I'll go for
Paris I've put Madrid I've also gone
Paris you've got Paris I did yeah Paris
Madrid Paris Paris yeah you're wrong
it's Moscow do you know what also I
don't like the smugness like you know
the answers and you're like you're wrong
I like because he's reading them
he's got God complex about it yeah
you're reading them you're learning the
same time you find out a day before
using it now get off your high horse fam
yeah literally and relax stuck in your
Ivory Tower chatting [__] you know ah I
know my country's in it no you don't yes
I do bro I knew all of these anyway say
less Russia do you know what I was so
good I was thinking I was thinking I
thought you know let me Moscow
yeah yeah Russia in it Russia but if
you've read Russia you've been wrong
bro
get off your horse
this mouse this mouse now all right next
one next one next one next one next one
you're ready Baku
is the capital city of which country
think about this think about this
kid you would know if you've seen a
certain yeah I know uh REM
yeah I'm winging it of course okay let's
go for your wig one first I'm going
Singapore from Singapore okay uh Alice
wow I went Japan uh Saudi Arabia
sorry guys yes
what do you think is now now that you
know you're wrong damn ends in it it's
them Saudi ends that's why I said I've
got it wrong but I've got it right the
stem ends bro
uh Albania nice it's them Saudi ends bro
what begins with a should I say it yeah
Azerbaijan Azerbaijan yeah last one yeah
namely the capital city of the country
that's adjacent to Portugal
you just need to know your maps in it
yeah I think so yeah I think if
hopefully in my mind
geographically speaking if Italy is
adjacent to Portugal
then I would say Rome
I've got nothing
yeah Euro pass
it's Madrid bro literally no one cares
so
let's take a little break we're just
spreading awareness today yeah mum we're
doing up awareness today man we're
helping you guys out on a Munch thing on
a scranting on a scrissanting on a Munch
team on a convenient budget-friendly
scram munchie Munch things facts facts
so we've been in the uh the hellofresh
game for a minute and uh yeah man yeah
man turns out of patterns the ones I
picked are chicken and spicy or chicken
and spinach Curry sorry sweet and sticky
Chicken on Rice spicy sticky beef and
the best thing about it is all of them
comes with all of them comes to like
pictures of what you need obviously
everything comes in in the in the bag as
well yeah yeah yeah it's just it just
looks presentable you know what I mean
it looks it gases me to make sure I've
got to make it correctly
yes yes
this one I made earlier yeah I promise
box
me as well because obviously I love to
cook and so do I sometimes your boy's
got four recipes in the Noggin
It's either chicken or ice bag bowl or a
resort if I'm feeling it and then you
just recycle the whole bag
and hello fresh has patterned us yeah
you've got chicken and tarragon
sometimes I'm not gonna buy it I need it
brought to me yeah facts so yeah guys if
you want to jump in if you want to get
involved your boys have got you sorted
actual so pay attention real quick sort
it out now and let us know what you
think if you want to get involved a
discount code is shits and gigs
obviously now listen guys meals start
from just three pound and 15 Pence per
person cheap and that's before the
discount I'm about to tell you about so
with that discount code you will get 60
off your first spot one six bro six zero
sixty percent off the first box and then
25 off the next eight boxes after that
crazy and then they're gonna throw in
some free gifts along with those boxes
as well guys so crazy one more time from
the top hellofresh.co.uk the discount
code to shifts and gigs and that's gonna
get you 60 off the first Box 25 off the
next eight plus some free zazas yeah man
you man are gonna be scranning yeah
we're gonna be scrambling that together
guys so let's make life easier let's
make life cheaper it's a hell of fresh
thing thanks enjoy okay guys let's take
a very very quick break to keep the
lights on in this Pang Studio by shed in
love to our boys and girls over at
manscape who are killing the game [__]
especially
tackling crotch discomfort guys as per
if you are struggling with crotch
discomfort fear no more because they're
kings of crotch Comfort manscapes have
spent two years designing the most
comfortable boxer briefs out there
they're Sleek soft comfortable flexible
and the brand new boxes 2.0 from
madscape take your balls from to the
Royal bull Throne the global leaders in
below the waist grouping of the
lawnmower 4.0 for the trimming so you
can wear the box as 2.0 for the chilling
guys if you want to get involved like
your cold dad is over here all you need
to do is head on over to manscape.com
and use the code sng zero November Golf
and that's going to give you 20 off plus
free shipping worldwide guys let's get
back to the episode thank you very much
um right cool so moving on I wanted to
talk about the film air it's still not
going to be out by the time this comes
out right no it comes on the fifth yep
um why am I sitting like this I like it
though
um
distinguished it is good for your hips
um I'll open those [__] up so yeah
it's amazing as lit bro as a really
really air is lit and I'm gonna put my
hands up
uh Viola Davis actress she's a champion
of the whole thing she's a champion of
the whole film bro and um yeah I'm not
usually like a
support and actor stroke actress like
it's the lead show so if if Matt Damon
and star of the show then what are we
doing I love me some Matt Damon so I
watched um
I watched The Departed for the first
time yesterday for the first time oh my
gosh what a great movie movie yeah yeah
Jack Nicholson yeah yeah it's a castle
Leo Matt Damon Damon
um Mark Wahlberg Alec um Alec Baldwin
[Music]
Dubai is a fantastic movie top 10 of all
time yeah really good really good movie
[__] um so yeah yeah air fantastic movie
top one of the top picks for movie of
the year for me facts um very
inspirational mom super inspirational so
if you guys aren't sure about it it is
um a film
following the story of how Michael
Jordan was signed to Nike uh for the
Jordan brand uh or the Air Jordan brand
and um it just goes to show like stuff
that you just would have never known so
like stuff like
um that Nike just had not
they had what a 15 share in basketball
17. 17 share
um in basketball and they they just
couldn't like no one in basketball gave
a damn about Nike and they could not
sign Ballers at all
um and they were just doing like white
joggers and Olympians and stuff like
that and no one cared
um and then
it goes to show the the story of how
um
what's his name Sunny
um who played by Matt Damon yes
basically went behind Nike's back to
poach Jordan from his confirmation with
Adidas
um and
the only way they were gonna get him
was to build an entire brand around him
and he did not have the permission of
Nike to do it so he went
through the houses to get it done
and eventually everything fell into
place and they created Air Jordan and it
shows that
Jordan was the first person I think I
don't know this might be wrong but it
was the first person in history to get
an equity share from each item sold yeah
sold
um at least in shoes
um and
it changed the game forever yeah
yeah he got a percentage share and still
now what they say he's making 400
million a year passively passively from
the Jordan brand just alone for us from
Jordan passive before he gets out of bed
bro that's 400 M's pass is crazy mum you
sold is it what do you say sold 2
billion the first year something like
that so they sold 168 million in their
first time and before that no Nike
athlete had ever sold over 3 million he
said yeah
um on their own like design or their own
thing no athlete had ever sold over 3
million so he was like all right cool
what's one percent of three million
we're gonna give him an extra 300K like
it's minor it's crazy what you said in
the cinema because you said I'm nervous
but I'm wearing jays right now so you
know what happened I I'm wearing Jordans
as we speak so I know it patterns yeah
but I'm so nervous for this piece yeah
bro and the pitch was uh Matt Damon yeah
actor Matt Davis
actor very very good movie guys uh make
sure you definitely definitely check out
air um out on the 5th of April
um yeah you really won't regret mum
honestly you won't describe Sasha buff
movie it's not too long it's like an
hour on 45 Aaron 50 and it's well paced
all the characters are amazing and
they've just they didn't rush it and it
didn't also like take too long with
anything everything was based out well
it was such a good movie yeah it was
paying so Random REM will be able to
help me with this I've started a little
bit of Married at First Sight
I've seen the first two episodes are we
in the first episode we're in the
trailer okay because I I've seen people
DM me saying I'm surprised you've not
talked about mafsa because you guys are
in the first first episode that's what I
said but I didn't I didn't we're not in
it yeah we're in it for like literally
0.6 seconds okay
um but yeah we're there bro come on man
we're there on the other side of the
world we're there on in I'm in your
living room bro [__] okay say less um
so
yeah this season
slight caveat I feel like the REM have
you watched any other Seasons no
actually it's not okay you won't be able
to wait on this one then but
ah they've obviously been doing this for
a while now and I feel like this season
is the most scripted
it feels that even from fam this one all
the other ones I've watched seem super
natural and juicy obviously there's
little bits of script in there but this
one is given like Made in Chelsea like
it oh bro there was a scene I watched
yesterday so I skipped because I put it
on in the hotel yesterday and it was
like however many episodes I don't know
where they're at now okay because I've
only watched episode one and two and
then I skipped forward and one
hang Ting cheated well she's she's
paying me she's not banging but she's uh
for her man she's banging okay for her
man yeah she's banging okay
and um
yeah so she lips the next man light skin
guy say less but it's scripted because
she cheated on her man with this
light-skinned on and the light-skinned
dawned whole narrative is that he's a
cheat
okay so he went in there
said he's a cheat like nine times they
proper went home on the fact there's a
cheat to the point where you're like why
does he keep saying he's a g just marry
him stop saying he's a cheat
um so he went in there like I've got a
horrible past I cheated on someone then
it got bought up again oh I haven't got
the best pass I've cheated on someone in
the past then it went up again oh I've
got cheats on the person I kept thinking
why they why are they hammering this
cheating thing so hard and then a few
episodes later his lips in next man's
gal
um and then the way the girl broke it
down to the husband was so scripted yeah
it was oh really yeah so scripted he
seemed genuinely vexed okay he was
destroyed yeah yeah
he's bad as hell and um then he went to
console his Bridge went to console him
and the Brethren cannot act worth a damn
he was like oh my God lips homeboy and
he was like oh my God
oh my God what are you telling me mate
I'm so oh I'm so angry for you that's
poor that's poor it was [__] he's like
let me give you a hug and you're like
bro what am I watching his thing's bad
as well Adam's thing no no no no no no
no no no Adam's thing is not bad oh okay
so the light skin guy who's a cheat I
can see here why he's a cheeks no
offense his wife is a facial liar let me
look at them yeah she's a makeup artist
and when she's got the makeup done buddy
to know
yeah when she wakes up in the morning my
guy yeah swear I ain't even seen Elena
the day after their wedding bro they
woke up he couldn't look at her oh she
was laying on his chest he was looking
on the window
that's um very Peak bro she looks
different in the morning it's Peak
um
and yeah she parred him as well because
he doesn't make any pee yeah yeah yeah
yeah he's a brand like on a startup team
yeah yeah is it this is this the cost is
the right cast season 10.
so that Duncan brother is handsome as
[__] yeah yeah oh he's handsome
um yeah so up above him Bronte
Alyssa Alyssa which one oh no oh Bronte
sorry yeah yeah her man her and her man
bro they've banged on the first night
banged on the first night but that it
was dead did it work out I don't know if
he's on a on a like a nut fan you need
to watch it yeah
he is he's emotionally
he's not there yeah he just doesn't know
how to he doesn't take any
responsibility for anything okay he puts
it all on Bronte okay and he just makes
her the gas lighting ability this
breakfast is out of this world okay okay
banged on the first night because when
he met her he was like you're banging
bro yeah yeah and then her Brethren's
Ops because her bedroom
crashed the whole wedding day and was
like he's got a gal outside
and he said as soon as this massive
thing's done and I'll get my Blue Tick
I'm coming back to clap and it's going
to be a me and new thing and she was
like gang I'm waiting she's 20 young
Ting and then oh what the [__] her
Brethren who by the way is banging Sam
who brunchies
Caitlyn is I don't know who it was no no
she wasn't she's not contestant she's a
red shoes she was at the wedges yeah she
was supposed to be a bridesmaid for
Bronte but she wasn't but yeah she was
awesome
Jesus she's cheeked up oh say I'll watch
it yeah yeah
the shape was crazy bro crazy and they
had it all distorted they didn't focus
on her properly but you could just see
She Bang it bro anyway she's off because
she was like your husband's got a thing
outside I heard about it yeah he's
trying to get famous and he's going to
go out and leave you so she was like
walk on for this and then thing is she
was actually telling the truth but she
started complaining she was like how's
she gonna do this thing and not make me
a bridesmaid how's it going to do this
thing so it made it look like she's just
Ops so as soon as the as soon as Bronte
found out like oh you're moaning about
being a bridesmaid you don't really care
about it he probably hasn't got a team
outside he definitely has he definitely
has he even was like I'm not about that
life he never said there wasn't a thing
outside yeah he just said I'm a changed
man I'm in here to be in here yeah he
didn't say he didn't even recognize what
she was saying yeah yeah
I'm here right now yeah yeah yeah yeah
show me something take this show me take
me as I am yeah take me as I am show me
sign yeah say bang the first night and
then he's a not emotionally dare so
she's all trying to lips on all sorts he
just turned her over and bang
and then the next day finally couldn't
look her eyes at each other and he fan
she was like can we just talk about it
and he was like brother I'm not being
funny I don't find you attractive
anymore wow he was like last night was
so mad to me I can't even look at you
wait they've married they're married
right now he's like I can't look at you
bro you just not a dick he's just not I
just said yuck I'm over there
I'm over this whole show
yeah I needed that get me home to my 20
year old thing and run me my Blue Tick
this is [__] this is all [__]
and it's episode two yeah that was
episode two yeah that was early wow yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah it gets
worse from there oh fam how many times
is it every day uh it's like it's like
Monday to Thursday
um 7 7 30. so yeah I've only seen bits
and Bobs so then the mixed race brought
up he put his foot in it so he's on a
startupting he does some like raffle his
business is like he does like a [__]
Facebook raffle tape mix race Brothers
and
um so he's his girl's Asian uh Sandy
yeah yeah she's um is that the one that
he couldn't see her face in the morning
night and day bro yeah Adam is Adam
mixed race with tanel oh tanelle not an
Asian thing to know oh tonight yeah yeah
night and day bro her makeup is night
and day anyway so yeah they did a thing
and she's like obviously their culture
is like I need the my man to have stuff
patterned so
she's gone
um like so what do you do for work he's
like I'll run this like this bet in
business this gambling business it's
like little raffle Ting and then he goes
and I'm thinking about starting a
podcast she rolled her eyes the whole
audience so did I I was like you can't
say stuff like that that's the one taboo
bro you don't tell a girl I might start
a podcast
so she literally ran straight to the the
room where you do the the one to one
straight in there he's broke
he's broke and he's got no prospects
I can't live like this wow it's broke
he's got no Prospect he has to be at the
top before you secure a thing you have
to have made it yeah I might start oh
God broke as hell so the next morning
she was like big man Ting no offense how
are you making money and he was like why
you ask me about money she was like but
man I can't have your you in my stomach
I know that you ain't got money where's
your money I need to know your state
we've got a life together and he was he
had an argument he was basically like my
life is my life like I'm not trying to
live poor so like
just believe that I want the best for
myself and if you think about the best
for myself then you should trust that I
want the best for everyone else but also
it's not good at me about money and then
she was like facts I'm sorry I'm not
trying to make you feeling insignificant
but also get some money because you're
talking about podcasts yeah yeah raffles
he's got nothing solidified she said how
are you making an income in fact he
wants to start a party he's doing
Raffles and what was the third thing you
said
um it's crypto crypto yeah yeah
it's all mad so anyway she was like this
is all long but she forgave him went on
from that because she forgave him for
his transgressions I was like all right
cool and he just won't stop saying he's
a cheat after all this crypto stuff he
keeps telling everyone he's a cheat so
hop skip jumped to where I clicked on
last night I don't know how many
episodes I've missed yeah yeah his lips
the Baddie who is married to one guy
with long hair okay he's emotional let
me see I know he's adamant
Adam lips Claire Claire who is with
Jesse Jesse Yeah Yeah Jesse came in with
an icklist and was like this [__]
give me the but then he went to Cameron
was like to be fair when you're that
banging ick me when you're that banging
yeah who's this thing is
the x that he had about her okay she's a
crystal
chicks star signs all of that he went
too far at first because he was like she
was like oh what's the outside of you
and he's like [__] sake and he was
like I want a divorce yeah I hate star
science things everyone's like calm down
bro calm down and he was like all right
bet then she took him outside I was like
I've Got Crystal for you and I was like
okay to be fair I'm not dealing with
this kind of stuff but then he turned
around and was like if you're that bad
I'll hold your question yeah so then he
turned to her and was like if it means
something to you it means something to
me run me to Christian let's go my guy
yeah then he said you're also you're
[__] annoying sometimes just stop
talking she's like you're always like
other sand is so nice the sky is so nice
you're always talking he fan what is it
that um
he was moving to her and she was like
fam she said you're not my person yeah I
felt it when she said that she said you
know what bro you're not my person
because you're gunning for me yeah
you're gunning for me
personal and you're talking about shut
up he said suck because he told her yeah
shush
yeah she said you're not my person pop
skip jump a few they went out got wasted
she was lips and Adam the cereal cheat
yeah oh she lipsed him yeah interesting
so yeah Adam didn't she had a guilty
conscience had to tell him yeah that's
the bit that sounded a bit scripted when
she told him okay he was not scripted he
broke his heart he went to smash the
crystal on the floor okay bro and she he
was like don't chat to me shut up Adam
had no intention of telling anyone [__]
[__] he literally went up to Adam was
like yo let's go have a chat even when
it's just them two alone he was like so
what go on Adam's like I don't know what
you're talking about my life and I was
like I'm dying with this I'm dying with
this information this is I don't care
what she told me I'm dying with this
information because he even said it you
know what she told me and he was like
who told you once tell me tell me I need
you to say a word for word before I
implicate my it's my happiness he knows
how to cheat
Adam knows how to cheat he's like I'm
letting you say word for word what you
know yeah and then I'll tell you if it's
true facts so um I don't know what
you're talking about okay and then
obviously they put him in the spot was
like tell your missus or I'm telling her
so he was like [__] sake bro so he went
and told his Mrs he did a softener blow
at all he was like look so obviously I
love you in it but
you know when we went out we was all
drunk in it like it was you were dead
like you know we went out with that
obviously me and Claire was outside it
was just out she was kept trying to make
me Vape I don't want to [__] Vape
yeah and then we were just outside and
then for some reason she was here and I
was here and I just lips are in it that
was basically his explanation she said
yeah she said pull it back yeah what
what did you say I just lips they're
like I'm not I said I'm a cheap but I'm
not a cheat like but I did lips her them
she broke down ran to the brother who
got cheated on his own so both victims
are just hugging yeah
oh [__] it was mad it's Janelle by the
way not to know sorry all right cool I'm
gonna give a watch I'm gonna give a
watch it sounds like cause I've never
watched any fam this is why this is why
I didn't want to watch it because now
I'm locked in yeah it's juice it is
Juicy I'm locked they always get me
locked in all right and I love when the
tension starts to Bubble yeah yeah and
then someone with a bag and the
commitment ceremonies yeah the dinner
parties yeah how many weeks in is it now
they're halfway through the experiment
right now yeah yeah so they they're
quite deep in but it's not that many
apps though to be fair so okay I don't
know I'll watch online or whatever yeah
do you know the one thing that's
actually mad as well just to finish off
um is that never clocked you before
because there's like three Asians in
this one like an Indian girl then
Janelle there's a new yeah and there's a
half tiger as well right yeah yeah yeah
right and is there another Asian girl as
well I think this I think this Janelle
is half Thai well I'm assuming it's just
Taiwan she looks yeah then the Sunday no
no Janelle's not half Thai Janelle's
full-blown like Chinese or something
yeah sorry the one that you're talking
about is the newest girl in now I think
well I haven't seen her maybe she's bad
is she bad yeah she's she's stunning
what's her name I don't know Evelyn she
is
on here 26 year olds she's tidy yeah
she's good all right say this so
oh I forgot there's one yeah that's
gonna die
Farm there's one yard here with a
disease She's Not Gonna Die She's Not
Gonna Die she's gonna she's not he's
exaggerating she's not she's got a
disease bro we have to confess stuff and
she was like bro oh she got cystic
vibrations like yeah bam she's got
scissors I never heard of it I've heard
of cystic vibrations it's die on their
Flem bro it's very serious yeah but
she's not gonna die she has no
medications added years to her life he's
exaggerated he's taking his new meds so
she said it's calm man
said I'm not gonna lie yeah I'm in this
this thing for the Long Haul so if
you're gonna die you need to tell me
yeah she was like no no I've got new
meds he said what does that mean bro
yeah so yeah that anyway that's Cameron
and uh who's his thing Lindell yes
um anyway anyway Adam looks horrific in
this picture but um bro okay so the half
Thai one is uh Tani
Janelle is the full Asian one and then
Sandy the Indian one bro yes sorry yes
because it's mad when you rock up
because they do it in like their native
ceremony yeah so Sandy did full blown
yeah and a man's white so he doesn't
know anything about her yeah but he just
rocks up as he's golden elephants
everywhere and it's just like turns out
I'm Marrying an Indian thing like that
must be mad over what so wait pause the
premise of obviously he's Married at
First Sight but do they
are they walking down the island and
that's the first time they see each
other and get married yeah they've never
seen each other until they get to the
aisle
so bro he's rocking up to the wedding he
sees his side of the family he sees just
bear Indian people and he's looking
around and everything's red and there's
golden elephants and then like to deep
obviously you don't have an issue with
it yeah but like to de-think Rama
where's Indian yeah that's mad to me and
then same thing as well like when like
um like Janelle's there and like all her
family is Asian you're like raw turns
out my wife's Asian like cool but man
like I didn't even deep it and team as
well like if you're white and then the
whole side is black you're like brah I'm
marrying a black girl
interesting is it interracial marriage
we're just gonna see how it goes yeah
yeah and then you rock up and you're
like turns out we're having an Indian
wedding yeah and she was bro Sandy the
Indian one she did sign I wouldn't have
played these games bro so it was a tiny
little thing that she thought she was
funny I would rip that nose ring out
see him back because he doesn't know the
culture her man doesn't know the culture
so she was always it's part of our
culture to put like the flowers around
the neck and all them things okay okay
yeah yeah so she put it around him and
he's like all right cool he's trying to
be politely like bow and stuff like that
and he's like cool cool she was like now
you do me yeah and he went to put it out
she went haha and he if I ah
nah what his camera
stand still man she said ah stunt trying
to be funny like yeah and was like is
this part you can tell he's like is this
part of the thing he wants to dash her
and she was like now I'm joking
Australia
no that would have pissed me off that
would have pissed me off I've never met
you before don't [__] about I've never
met you before
fix up
bam this is one facts bro
oh yeah my question for you and answer
in the comments as well when was the
last time you told your parents you love
them
tell my mom I love her every single time
I talk to her
pretty much the same uh Dad I think I've
told my dad 11 twice in my life and I
hate it both times I I actually don't
think I've ever told my dad I love him
once I don't remember I got I did it as
a social experiment the first time when
I was like five oh you've had this story
yeah yeah you're saying good night good
night good night bro he taught me in I
was like good night he was like good
night and he turned off the light and I
was like love you he said and what's up
covers up my chest like one tears if I
don't want to see I just rolled over
[Music]
bullied by my uni girlfriend
in like second year
okay just tell him I love him when I was
yes yes yes yes I remember because you
gave me money yeah yeah you helped me
out with money and then uh I was like
gang safe and um she was there she was
like oh like you should tell him you
love him and I was like brother I'm not
I don't care how much money I'm not
doing that again yeah
um and she was like come on man like
he'd appreciate it I was like you don't
know him shut up you don't know what
he'll appreciate true and then she was
like bro just do it like you're being a
[__] like you just said you pee
um he didn't have to like tell him you
love him all right cool so I was like I
love you Dad and he said it back yuck it
made me feel weird
Fair um yeah same with you same answer
with you in terms of my mom every time
you speak
um tell her I love her she tells me she
loves me whatever same same I told you
I've said everyone to everyone here my
mom just checks up with me to see if I'm
alive
um my Pops I generally don't think I've
ever said I love you to my pops or vice
versa that I can recall
um do you know where that is do I know
why that is or do you have a theme as to
why you feel uncomfortable saying I love
you to your pups rather than I guess
it's just because we've never done it if
I grew up doing it then I wouldn't feel
uncomfortable doing it but um I've just
never done it
um and it's just forced like
I don't know yeah I've always done to my
mum so like now every single time I talk
to my mom will say it but like um yeah
it's just weird saying it to my dad I
don't know why I agree I agree it's in
the same way like
my mum it was also one of those ones
where my mom always
always colds as well my mom I speak to
my mom a lot more than I speak to my dad
that's the thing I can go six months and
not speak to myself yeah yeah yeah and
he won't even notice yeah and he can he
can Hollow me six months later and be
like how you been and it could just be a
conversation like what the [__] is
happening yeah you know what I mean are
you alive if I'm expecting my mom in six
months she's coming to the studio yeah
she's finding out everything she's
finding out everything do you know what
I mean yeah if I'm speaking my pops in
six months he will just build me be like
oh yeah I hope you're good yeah he won't
acknowledge he's been six years just
checking in yeah yeah just check it in
yeah so it's one of those ones it's
weird it's so weird
um answer in the comments as well guys
do you feel like you can say I love you
to your mum or your dad separately or is
it all yeah I'm interested what they do
say I'm sure the girls say I love you to
them yeah but yeah boys it's all weird
it's a good culture well guys we're
gonna wrap it there for today that was
cute that was a nice little one quite
hard
um so yeah obviously guys catch us on
Thursday patreon.com shits and gigs and
uh yeah man level of love
[Music]
thank you